three two
thank you
and welcome to this meeting of the
Northwest area planning today Wednesday
the first of July 2020 my name is
counselor mrs. Maggie Thompson I'm the
chairman of this committee this meeting
is held under new regulations which came
into effect on the 4th of April in
response to the Kovach 19 pandemic there
are just a few housekeeping issues to
run through including our new working
practices which have been implemented
due to the pandemic and the etiquette
for this meeting
first of all could I please ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off we're not addressing the
committee this will reduce background
noise and avoid any unintentional
disturbances the meeting will be hosted
remotely bar conferencing software which
allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting whilst
being able to protect themselves and
others and observe the government's
lockdown measures we may encounter some
glitches this afternoon it happened so I
hope that everyone will bear with us as
we get used to this new way of working
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded members and
officers during each item please use the
chat function of the meeting to indicate
if you wish to speak and I will then
advise invite you at the appropriate
time members are reminded that apart
from indicating you wish to speak or
that you have to leave the meeting the
chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose please do
not use the race hand function as this
is not available on all member devices
members the process this afternoon will
obviously be a little different from
what we're used to although we have done
this one before and for some items I may
invite each member to speak in turn
therefore I would encourage all members
to keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible please when speaking
and referring to agenda but I also
please ask everyone is directly
connected to a power supply so that
nobody drops out due to short battery
life and last if members need to leave
the meeting at any point please do make
this known and use the chat function to
signify the
you do need to leave now may I ask
officers taking part in meeting to
introduce themselves starting with mr.
Lee thank you and mr. Johnson
[Music]
thank you Miss all good afternoon my
name is Hannah Bowles I'm a specialist
in development management good afternoon
Berner KDC clark to the committee today
thank you are there any other officers
present we need to introduce themselves
I had a request I noticed was could
someone help counselor chana join I'm
just throwing that out there I'm afraid
I'm not able to but she has right hello
I'm Lee in attendance for a little while
thank you we're just doing the roll call
so that's absolutely fine
Bernie could you please carry out the
roll call calling members in
alphabetical order and then inviting
other members in attendance to introduce
themselves thank you
yes madam chairman council has the
Durham yes I'm here that's the fleming
present as the Jarvis prison the keys
present its little present mrs. Thompson
present present cancer miss white I
think we may be having problems okay
thank you
Thank You chairman and the next item
items on the agenda is in fact
apologists for absent so man of those
please Branagh yes we received apologies
from councillors Bamford Morley and
white thank you
moving on to item 3 this is minutes of
the 8th of June 2020 these are found on
pages 7 to 18 for me the chat function
isn't working for me again I don't
understand that councillor Morris but
thank you I will ask the IT and
attendance to see if they can help you
with that councillor Morris okay thank
you
apologies could we please have those in
attendance burner too or no counselors
chana and councillor Morris thank you
right sorry if you can hear me but I am
listening in my mobile I'm working but I
am just listening I won't be
participating that's councillors stamp
thank you right can I take those minutes
as read members and can you use the chat
or if you can't manage that can we speak
up if you have anything to query on the
accuracy agreed if they can speak so
members can you please confirm you agree
those or indicate if you disagree right
declarations of interest I have to read
all this out it's a nature of any
disposable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct the members members are reminded
that they also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare please use the
chat function now to indicate and I will
invite you to swing chairman chairman on
january interest as a member of Essex
County Council who are statutory console
TV assassins thank you as I mean
attendance I don't know if I need you
because I'm not actually involved in the
decision-making but I will just declare
that I'm also in Essex County counselor
for the record but I don't believe you
know as I'm not involved
I don't normally sit on a committee I
mean in attendance but I just highlight
that for openness and transparency
that's fine Thank You councillor Channel
you're absolutely right decision making
you don't need to but if you feel have
feel that's absolutely fine I need to
declare non-pecuniary if it even counted
on the member of Tulsa Knight Parish
Council who have given a view on this
although I've always reserved the right
to take a different view when I have
more information in front of me also
full disclosure I live about half a mile
from the only application we have here
but I can't see it from my house I can't
hear it and the only contact I have with
it is if I Drive past like the other
member of the public
I'm also acquainted with the neighbors
but I don't believe any of them have
commented right so we move to item five
all food eight bottles at nights could
we have the presentation please both
yeah Thank You Tara
so planning permission is sought for the
donate demolition of an esteemed wedding
and erection of a new dwelling here we
have the location plan block plan which
shows the replacement running a started
over the footprint of the existing
dwelling we've got the existing
elevations the proposed elevations
listing floor plans and the proposed
floor plans and then we've got some site
photographs the proposed replacement
dwelling is a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme that was
subsequently dismissed to appeal the
amendments to the scheme are considered
to overcome that concerns concerns
raised by the plan in inspector in
relation to the impact from the
character and appearance the area due to
the reduction in scowl alone small
prominence of the proposed wedding and
the change in difference thank you yeah
I'm afraid I didn't quite get it
I'm terribly sorry miss could you just
finish off the last couple of sentences
like so everyone has all the information
yeah thank you care so the amendment to
the scheme are considered to overcome
the concerns raised by the Planning
Center on the character and appearance
at the area due to the reduction in
scale and overall prominence and change
in appearance of the proposed wedding
therefore the proposed development is
recommended for approval thank you thank
you
[Music]
before that I'm going to ask if any
member wishes to second the motion to
approve as well the offices offices
recommendation any member I'm second
that counselor Siddal Thank You
councillor Sybil well thank you thank
you chairman I think this is almost
academic isn't it having having read the
government proposals for its review of
the planning system in about a month's
time they won't even need planning
permission to to do this sort of thing
and in fact they can probably revert to
their original their original design I
don't know if mr. Lee wants to comment
on that and I appreciate the fact that
we haven't had
written Slayton from government yet but
if PBL Zarate tasks I've been reading in
the press this morning the this
application is is pretty much academic
we haven't seen the statement it is a
there is clear guidance that there's a
direction of travel coming forward with
the committee development but at the
moment as we are unaware of what it is
specifically I wouldn't give it too much
why and as we do know sometimes the
legislation doesn't always mirror what
has been said but irrespective that I
don't think there any real issues with
the application you can see mr. Paul and
I would mean that members move the
recommendation Thank You chairman
Sherwin if I come back yes I agree with
mr. Lee it was it was just a an
interesting point that we we're probably
going to have to face in the next month
or so I have actually been reading quite
a lot of the trade journals this morning
from the building planning and
architecture organizations who aren't
generally in favor of it but I suspect
it's coming well I have the Jarvis yeah
thank you chairman just regarding this
application and I think we can all see
referring 5.2 point 11 12 13 and 14 that
it looks like all of the previous issues
that are a concern have been addressed
it looks like this proposed dwelling is
very similar to the one that's was he
being taken down and I think I think as
has been suggested we could fairly I'd
be very certainly very happy to promptly
move to look at the motion thank you
Jarvis got anyone else asking to speak
so fun yeah my two penises you know this
is their third go everyone seems to be
the officers are happy and their
neighbors are happy I see myself no
reason to do anything other than the
prove this so members could we have a
vote please on the on the officers
recommendation to approve with the
conditions are set out Sun Burnaby can
we just do a quick roll call completely
yes thank you German so it's four
against abstain cancer Durham great for
cancer mr. Fleming Oh mr. Jarvis hmm mr.
Keyes for as the siddle for mr. Thompson
obviously yes oh yes okay so that's six
four none against no abstentions
recommendation item six as any other
items of business the chairman of the
committee decides of urgent and there
are none so members I thank you for your
contributions this afternoon and thank
you to the offices in attendance I draw
the meeting to a close
I've got 140mm genius and as the meeting
is now closed members are advised not to
enter into any further discussion on
this forum and please leave meeting
promptly thank you very much
you